NEWT GINGRICH AND JEFF SESSIONS
ALSO CAME TO THE HOOSIER STATE
FOR THEIR OWN LAST-MINUTE
FACE-TO-FACE HUDDLE WITH THE
CANDIDATE AT A DOWNTOWN HOTEL.
HE ALSO REPORTEDLY CALLED CHRIS
CHRISTIE TODAY.
IF YOU ARE CONFUSED ABOUT WHERE
TRUMP STANDS ON THIS DECISION,
DON'T WORRY.
THE CANDIDATE CLEARED IT UP AND
INTO WITH BRETT PAIR OF FOX
NEWS.
DONALD TRUMP: THE GOVERNOR HAS
BEEN AMAZING.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
NEWT GINGRICH IS COMING IN TO
SEE ME.
CHRIS CHRISTIE IS SOMETHING I
HAVE LIKED FOR A LONG TIME.
HE IS A TOTAL PROFESSIONAL.
I AM NARROWING IT DOWN.
I AM AT THREE, POTENTIALLY FOUR.
BUT IN MY OWN MIND PROBABLY TO.
MARK: I HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
FOLLOW THE BOUNCING BALL FROM
INDIANAPOLIS TO CLEVELAND.
WHERE'S THE RUNNING MATE SEARCH
STAND?
JOHN: I THINK AFTER ALL THE
DRAMA OF TODAY WITH PANTS AND
WITH THINKING MAYBE HE'S THE
GUY.
THEN WE HEARD THAT SESSIONS AND
GINGRICH ARE ALSO ON THEIR WAY
TO INDIANA.
AND HE SPOKE TO CHRISTIE.
I THINK WE ARE NOT THAT FAR FROM
WHERE WE WERE 24 HOURS AGO WE
TALKED ABOUT ON THE SHOW.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A SHORT LIST
NOW AND THE SHORTLIST IS THREE
PEOPLE, GINGRICH CHRISTIE, MIKE
PENCE, AND MAYBE SESSIONS.
BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM IT IS MUCH
TO GO ON WITH SESSIONS.
DONALD TRUMP IS DOING FINAL CUT
CHECKS ON THESE MEN.
MARK: I THINK JEFF SESSIONS IS
BEING DONE AS A COURTESY.
THE OTHER THREE ARE VIABLE
CONTENDERS.
IF HE GOES WITH HIS HEAD TO
UNITE THE CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT
AND NOT RISK A RUNNING MATE WHO
CAUSE DISTRACTIONS HE WILL GO
WITH GOVERNOR MIKE PENCE.
IF HE GOES WITH THE PEOPLE HE
FEELS MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
PEOPLE GO WITH EITHER GINGRICH
OR CHRISTIE.
ONE THING WE DON'T KNOW IS THE
OFFENDING ISSUE.
BOTH GINGRICH AND CHRISTIE HAVE
KNOWN THINGS IN THEIR DOSSIERS
THAT COULD BE DISTRACTIONS.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW HOW HEAVILY
DONALD TRUMP IS WEIGHING THOSE
THINGS.
WE KNOW THAT THE BALANCE OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AMONG EVIL
AROUND HIM IS WEIGHTED MORE
TOWARD MIKE PENCE THAN THE OTHER
TWO.
JOHN: PAUL MATT FORTE LIKES THE
IDEA OF PENCE.
DONALD TRUMP STILL NEEDS TO
CONSOLIDATE REPORT -- SUPPORT
AMONG REPUBLICANS.
MIKE PENCE GIVES HIM THE CARD TO
PLAY WITH CONSERVATIVES.
PAUL RYAN A COMMENT ABOUT HOW HE
WOULD LIKE TO BE REASSURED THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS A GENUINE
CONSERVATIVE.
THE QUESTION OF A NOMINEE
LOOKING INTO THE EYES OF THESE
PEOPLE THAT HE WOULD NOT JUST BE
PUTTING ON THE TICKET AS A
COHORT ON THE ROAD IN A CAMPAIGN
SETTING BUT WHO HE WOULD LIKE TO
GOVERN WITH IF THEY BECOME
PRESIDENT IS A HUGE THING.
THAT GUT CHECK REALLY MATTERS.
HE DOESN'T SEE WHAT THE WHO'S
AFRAID OF DISTRACTIONS.
ON THE BASIS OF HOW HE HAS
CAMPAIGNED SO FAR.
MAYBE IT WILL MATTER SO MUCH.
HE COULD SAY SCREW IT, I WANT TO
BE WITH CHRISTIE.
HE IS MORE MY KIND OF GUY.
MARK: I THINK HE LIKES HIS OWN
DISTRACTIONS RATHER THAN OTHER
ONES.
JOHN: NEW DETAILS ABOUT THE
LINEUP OF THE UPCOMING
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL CONVENTION
IN PHILADELPHIA.
ELIZABETH WARREN, MICHELLE
OBAMA, BERNIE SANDERS ARE ALL
SCHEDULED TO SPEAK.
THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WILL TAKE
THE STAGE.
AMAZINGLY IT IS MOR
KNOW ABOUT THE REPUBLICAN
CONVENTION WHICH STARTS IN JUST
FIVE DAYS.
REPORTS ARE THE TRUMPS FAMILY
WILL PLAY A BIG ROLE.
SCOTT WALKER WILL BE SPEAKING.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE A FULL
SCHEDULE.
MANY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LACK OF ORGANIZATION AND
LOGISTICS AND SECURITY TO DEAL
WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DEMONSTRATORS ON THE STREETS OF
CLEVELAND.
HOW LIKELY IS IT THAT THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL CONVENTION
IS GOING TO BE A TOTAL BUST?
MARK: THEY ARE WELL BEHIND IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY SAID
PUBLICLY.
THE DONALD TRUMP OPERATION CAN
DEFY GRAVITY AS LONG AS THEY
FILL THE TIME OF THE STAGE AND
STUFF HAPPENS EVERY DAY THAT
FEEDS THE JOURNALISTS.
THEY WILL BE OK.
IT'S NOT THAT MUCH PROGRAMMING.
IT'S NOT 24 HOURS.
IT IS A HIGH WIRE THING AND THEY
ARE A LITTLE BIT IN DANGER OF
FALLING OFF THE WIRE.
JOHN: THE BIG BODY AT -- CAVEATS
IS THE SECURITY ISSUE ON THE
STREETS IN CLEVELAND.
GIVEN WHAT IS HAPPENED IN
AMERICA OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST WEEK.
IMAGES OF CHAOS AND DISORDER,
THOSE KINDS OF IMAGES COULD
QUICKLY OVERWHELM ANYTHING GOING
ON THE CONVENTION STAGE.
IF THAT HAPPENS THIS COULD
REALLY BE A MESS.
NOT JUST IN TERMS OF TELEVISION
PRODUCTION BUT POLITICALLY FOR
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS CHANCES TO
BECOME PRESIDENT.
MARK: IF THEY HAD MORE BANDWIDTH
AMONG THE HIGH COMMAND THEY
COULD BE COORDINATED WITH THE
SECRET SERVICE LOCAL POLICE IN A
MORE CONFIDENT WAY.
TAKING THE SPEAKERS IS THE FIRST
STEP.
THEN YOU GOT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
ORDER PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING IN AN
COORDINATING THEIR
PRESENTATIONS.
YOU DON'T WANT ANOTHER CLINT
EASTWOOD SITUATION.
THEY'RE TAKING A RISK HERE.
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE TRUMP'S
SHOWMANSHIP AND HIS FAMILY MAYBE
ONE PAPER OVER.
ALMOST A WEEK AFTER THE DALLAS
SHOOTING THAT KILLED FIVE POLICE
OFFICERS HILLARY CLINTON INVOKES
ABRAHAM LINCOLN'S HOUSE DIVIDED
SPEECH TODAY WITH HER OWN PLEA
FOR NATIONAL UNITY IN REMARKS AT
THE OLD ILLINOIS STATE CAPITAL.
HER SPEECH WHICH CAME ONE DAY
AFTER PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
PRESIDENT BUSH SPOKE ABOUT
MEMORIAL URGED AMERICANS TO
APPRECIATE THE DIFFICULT WORK
THE POLICE DO AND ALSO CALLED
FOR ENDING THE SYSTEMATIC RACISM
HILLARY CLINTON: AS SOMEONE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A HOTLY FOUGHT
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN I CAN'T CLAIM
THAT MY WORDS AND ACTIONS
HAVEN'T SOMETIMES FUELED THE
PARTISANSHIP THAT OFTEN STANDS
IN THE WAY OF PROGRESS.
FOUGHT
POLITICALI RECOGNIZE THAT I HAVO
BETTER.
IN TIMES LIKE THESE WE NEED A
PRESIDENT WHO CAN HELP US
TOGETHER.
NOT TO US APART.
THAT IS WHY I BELIEVE DONALD
TRUMP IS SO DANGEROUS.
HE SAYS THAT HE DOESN'T WIN IN
NOVEMBER WE WON'T HAVE A COUNTRY
ANYMORE.
AMERICA IS NOT GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SURVIVE.
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
THIS MAN IS THE NOMINEE OF THE
PARTY OF LINCOLN.
WE ARE WATCHING HIS BECOME THE
PARTY OF DONALD TRUMP.
THAT IS NOT JUST A HUGE LOSS FOR
OUR DEMOCRACY.
IT IS A THREAT TO IT.
MARK: THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN SAID
THESE WERE MAJOR REMARKS.
DONALD TRUMP HAS CALLED HIMSELF
THE LAW AND ORDER CANDIDATE.
JOHN: SHE IS TRYING TO BE THE
CANDIDATE OF OPTIMISM.
GUARDED OPTIMISM, REALISTIC
OPTIMISM.
ALSO SOMEONE WHO TRAFFICS IN THE
KIND OF APOCALYPTIC RHETORIC
THAT IS SOMETIMES APPEALING TO
CERTAIN SEGMENT BUT NOT
GENERALLY.
I CAN'T FIGURE TIME IT HAS EVER
ONE GENERAL ELECTION.
SHE FRAMED IT RELATIVELY WELL
FROM HER POINT OF VIEW.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THE TRUMPS
MESSAGES AND STILL POWERFUL.
THEY SAY THAT TRUMP WON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE ANY MISTAKES.
SHE IS NOT TOO FAR OFF THAT.
SHE SAID THE E-MAILS WERE A
MISTAKE.
FOR HER TO SAY TODAY IN A
HEARTFELT WAY THAT SHE HAS BEEN
PART OF THE PARTISANSHIP.
THAT IS SMART.
HER ARGUMENT IN THE END ABOUT
TRUMP IS THAT HE IS UNREASONABLE
AND I AM REASONABLE.
THAT WAS A PRETTY BIG CONCESSION
TO MAKE.
LET'S SEE IF SHE CAN KEEP HIS
TONE UP.
IF THIS IS A ONE-OFF GIVEN THE
VEEPSTAKES EVERYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON.
I'M NOT SURE THE SPEECH WILL
BREAK THROUGH FOR VERY MANY
VOTERS.
UNLESS SHE SUSTAINS THE TONE AND
THE IDEAS.
JOHN: IT IS LESS THAN A WEEK
AWAY FROM ALL THE STUFF THAT
HAPPENED LAST WEEK IN
MINNEAPOLIS AND THEN IN DALLAS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY WHO WANT A UNIFYING
FIGURE NOT A DIVISIVE FIGURE.
WHEN WE COME BACK, DONALD TRUMP
PICKING UP MOMENTUM IN A LOT OF
BATTLEGROUND STATE POLLS.
AFTER THIS BREAK.
♪
JOHN: WELCOME BACK.
WE HAD A TSUNAMI OF BATTLEGROUND
STATE POLLS TODAY.
DONALD TRUMP IS GAINING GROUND
ON HILLARY CLINTON IN THESE
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
DONALD TRUMP TIED WITH CLINTON
IN OHIO WHERE HE TRAILED OR BY
SIX POINTS COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO.
SHE IS AHEAD BY 13 IN COLORADO.
IN WISCONSIN SHE IS UP BY SIX.
THE DONALD TRUMP IS CLOSE TO THE
GAP IN OTHER STATES INCLUDING
THE KEY BATTLEGROUND STATE OF
FLORIDA.
THAT IS AN 11 POINT SWING IN
TRUMPS DIRECTION IN LESS THAN A
MONTH.
WE TALKED ABOUT A NEW POLL THAT
SHOWED HILLARY WITH A BIG LEAD
AMONG COLLEGE-EDUCATED VOTERS.
THAT DOESN'T USUALLY HAPPEN FOR
DEMOCRATS.
LOOKING AT ALL THESE POLLS, ONE
OF THE REALITIES AND
IMPLICATIONS FOR THESE
CANDIDATES?
PEOPLE GOING TO HAVE TO
GET USED TO SEEING A DIFFERENCE
DURING THE NATIONAL POLLS AND
THE STATE POLLS.
THE POLITICAL REALITY IS IT IS
GREAT FOR TRUMP UNEVENLY
CONVENTION.
IT ALLOWS HIM TO FEEL LIKE HE
HAS GOT THE MOMENTUM.
TO ARGUE TO THE DELEGATES WERE
THEY MIGHT BE SOME WAVERING.
THIS GUY CAN WIN 200 AND
ELECTORAL VOTES SO GET IN LINE.
THE CLINTON FOLKS ARE NOT HAPPY
ABOUT IT ON ONE LEVEL.
IF THEY CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
THEIR BIGGEST CHALLENGE IS
GETTING DEMOCRATS, DONORS AND
ACTIVISTS AND VOLUNTEERS, TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY COULD LOSE AND
TO BE ENERGIZED IN THE WAY THEY
NEED TO BE.
JOHN: MANY OF THESE POLLS WERE
CONDUCTED IN THE WAKE OF THE FBI
DIRECTORS RULING LAST WEEK.
HE TOOK IT AS A WOODSHED EVEN AS
HE LET HER OFF THE HOOK.
IT SEEMS THOUGH FOR SOME NUMBER
OF VOTERS JAMES COMEY'S
CRITICISMS OF CLINTON HAVE SUNK
IN.
IN ALL OF THESE STATES DONALD
TRUMP HAS GAINED SOME GROUND.
THAT IS THE BIG TAKE AWAY HERE.
WE CAN'T TELL THE CAUSATION YET.
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THE FBI
DECISION ALTHOUGH SPEARING HER
FROM THE EXISTENTIAL THREAT OF
PROSECUTION MAY HAVE TAKEN SOME
OF THE TEMPORARY TOLL ON HER
POLE STANDING.
MARK: IF IT IS TRUE THAT THESE
POLLS REPRESENT AN ACCURATE
NOTION THAT TRUMP IS DOING
BETTER, THE PRESS MAY BE
OVEREMPHASIZED DONALD TRUMP'S
FAILURE IN HIS SPEECHES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE JAMES COMEY
THING.
IT HAPPENED ALL ON ITS OWN.
HE DID NEED TO TALK AS MUCH
ABOUT IT AS HIS CRITICS SAID HE
DID.
JOHN: YOU COULD ARGUE THAT IF
YOU DRIVEN THE MESSAGE HE WOULD
GOT AN EVEN BIGGER BOUNCE.
MARK: NAFTA THAT'S FAST BETWEEN
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE RUTH BADER
GINSBURG AND DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS BEEN A FEW DAYS SINCE
JUSTICE GINSBURG TOLD THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS IN THE NEW YORK
TIMES THAT SHE DIDN'T WANT TO
THINK ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
DONALD TRUMP IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
SHE TOLD CNN LEGAL ANALYST JONAS
KUBIK THAT DONALD TRUMP IS A
FAKER AND CALLED HIM OUT FOR NOT
RELEASING HIS TAX RETURNS.
DONALD TRUMP CALLED THOSE
COMMENTS INAPPROPRIATE.
ONLY THE REPUBLICAN FRONT-RUNNER
WENT AS FAR AS TO SEND A
MIDNIGHT TWEET THAT JUSTICE
GINSBURG HAS EMBARRASSED ALL OF
US.
HER MIND IS SHOT.
RESIGN.
IS A GOOD IDEA FOR TRUMP TO
PICKS THIS FIGHT?
JOHN: IT WAS VERY UNUSUAL FOR
JUSTICE GINSBURG TO DO WHAT SHE
DID.
PROBABLY INAPPROPRIATE.
MARK: DEFINITELY INAPPROPRIATE.
TO BE CRITICIZED BY DEMOCRATS IN
THIS PARTISAN.
WAS EXTRAORDINARY.
IF A REPUBLICAN JUSTICE HAD DONE
THIS, THE WORLD EXPLODED.
JOHN: THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
DONALD TRUMP GETS MUCH BENEFIT
OUT OF ATTACKING RUTH GINSBURG
THE WAY HE IS ATTACKING HER.
IF DONALD TRUMP IN A SOBER WAY
WERE TO CALL ATTENTION TO THIS,
EVERYONE IN THE WORLD WHO IS NOT
HOPELESSLY PARTISAN WOULD SAY
DONALD TRUMP HAS A POINT THERE.
BUT TO SAY THAT HER MIND IS
SHOT.
IT IS A CHILDISH RESPONSE.
IT PLAYS INTO THE NOTION THAT
DONALD TRUMP'S TEMPERAMENT IS
NOT THAT GREAT.
MARK: IF THEY ARE USING THE
COURT TO ENERGIZE THE BASE.
IT IS GOOD FOR TRUMP EVEN TO DO
IT THIS WAY.
HE WANTS TO PERSONALIZE THE
NOTION THAT THE LIBERALS ON THE
SUPREME COURT NEED TO BE
REPLACED BY CONSERVATIVES.
THIS IS GOING TO GET ATTENTION.
BOTH SIDES TRY TO MAKE THE COURT
AN ISSUE AND IT IS VERY HARD TO
DO.
HE DOES HAVE SOME PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT RESIZING GINSBURG.
-- CRITICIZING GINSBURG.
JOHN: IT IS AN INCREDIBLE FIGHT.
JUST AMAZING.
UP NEXT, WE HAD TWO STRATEGIC
MASTERMINDS.
JAMES CARVILLE AND I NEED IT
ANITA DUNN.
AFTER THESE MESSAGES.
♪
MARK: WITH US IS DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST JAMES CARVILLE AND
ALSO ANITA DUNN.
SO IS THE GOOD AND THE BAD.
ANITA: I THINK PICKING PANTS
COULD HELP THEM CARRY INDIANA.
THAT'S THE GOOD.
HE IS NOT EXCITING.
HE IS NOT DYNAMIC.
HE HAS SOME REAL NEGATIVES FROM
HIS TIME AS GOVERNOR.
JAMES CARVILLE: I THINK WE HELP
THE DEMOCRATS CARRY INDIANA.
HE COULD WIN THE GOVERNOR'S
RACE.
HOW IS HE GOING TO HELP WIN THE
PRESIDENCY.
JOHN: YOU BOTH THINK MIKE PENCE
IS A BAD IDEA.
WHAT ABOUT CHRIS CHRISTIE?
ANITA: CHRIS CHRISTIE IS A GOOD
RUNNING MATE IF THE ONLY THING
HE EVER HAD TO DO WAS GO DEBATE
WHOEVER THE DEMOCRATS NOMINATED
FOR VICE PRESIDENT.
UNFORTUNATELY HE BRINGS HIS
BAGGAGE AND HIS PERSONALITY WITH
HIM.
THAT OUTWEIGHS HIS PERFORMANCE
IN DEBATES.
JAMES CARVILLE: CHRIS CHRISTIE
CRUSHED MARCO RUBIO.
THERE IS A LOT OF DOWNSIDES TO
CHRIS CHRISTIE.
IT ASSUMES THAT THE DEMOCRATIC
VICE PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE CAN'T
GET READY FOR THE DEBATE WHICH
IS A PRETTY BIG ASSUMPTION.
ANITA: IT SCARES ME A JAMES SIRE
AGREEING SO MUCH.
MARK: YOU HAD A DECADE-LONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH NEWT GINGRICH.
IS HE A BETTER CHOICE?
JAMES CARVILLE.
IF YOU TOOK THE COMBINED
APPROVAL RATINGS IN EACH OF
THEIR STATES I DON'T THINK
WITHIN UP TO 75.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE THIS
ARTICLE IN THE TIMES TODAY ABOUT
THE DEEP BENCH IN THE TALENT AT
HOW MULTIETHNIC THE PARTY WAS.
THIS IS A REFLECTION OF A DEEPER
PROBLEM THAT THEY HAVE.
GINGRICH IS AN AGGRESSIVE GUY.
HE COULD ATTACK HILLARY.
THAT'S ALL I CAN THINK OF.
ANITA: THEY NATURALLY DID
HAVE SOME GOOD POTENTIAL CHOICES
BUT TRUMP HAD INSULTED THEM.
NEWT GINGRICH TEMPERAMENTALLY IS
SOMEBODY THAT TRUMP IS
COMFORTABLE WITH.
IT IS IMPORTANT.
NOTHING SAYS FUTURE LIKE
SOMEBODY WHO WAS SPEAKER IN
1995.
MARK: OR FIRST LADY BACK THEN.
JOHN: WHAT ABOUT JEFF
SESSIONS?
WOULD JEFF SESSIONS BE A
STRONGER CHOICE?
ANITA: I'M NOT SURE WHAT
JEFF SESSIONS WOULD BRING TO IT
OTHER THAN SOMEBODY WHO HAS
SERVED IN THE CONGRESS.
SENATOR SESSIONS IS SOMEONE THAT
TRUMP SEEMS COMFORTABLE WITH AS
WELL.
HE IS VERY PARTISAN.
HE IS FROM THE DEEP SOUTH STATES
THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE
COMPETITIVE.
HE GIVES HIM THE ABILITY TO KEEP
IT -- IT SAY HE PICKED SOMEBODY.
JAMES CARVILLE.
: THE CHOICES I HAVE FOR VICE
PRESIDENT ARE VERY LIMITED.
AS I WOULD BE FOR PRESIDENT.
I CAN'T THINK THAT'S OBVIOUS.
MARK: MORE WITH THE DUO OF JAMES
CARVILLE AND ANITA DUNN AFTER
THIS.
♪
.
MARK: BACK NOW WITH JAMES
CARVILLE AND ANITA DUNN.
LAST SEGMENT, WE TALKED ABOUT
TRUMP'S VICE PRESIDENT OPTIONS.
LEAVE TIM KAINE ASIDE FOR A
SECOND.
WITH ANOTHER NAME THAT SHOULD BE
OUT THERE THAT YOU THINK WOULD
BE A GOOD ALTERNATIVE TO CANA
SHE DECIDES AGAINST THEM?
ANITA: I'VE ALWAYS IN A FAN OF
HAVING ELIZABETH BORN ON THIS
TICKET.
ELIZABETH WORN IS GREAT
CAMPAIGNER AND SHE KENEXA
EXTREMELY WELL WITH VOTERS
CONCERNED ABOUT ECONOMIC
INEQUALITY.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A GREAT
TICKET.
-- SHE CONNECTS EXTREMELY WELL
WITH VOTERS.
JAMES: I WOULD LOVE AN ELIZABETH
WARREN AND CHRIS CHRISTIE
DEBATE.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS PERFECT.
SHERROD BROWN, TOM VILSACK, THE
CASTRO'S -- I DON'T THINK WE ARE
GOING TO KNOW.
MY GUESS IS SHE'S GOING TO BE
VERY DELIBERATE, LISTEN TO
EVERYBODY, READ EVERYTHING AND
MAKE UP HER MIND LATER FOR TOP
IF HE PICKS CHRIS CHRISTIE,
PLEASE PICK ELIZABETH WORN
BECAUSE THAT VICE PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE WOULD BE ONE FOR THE
AGES.
JOHN: IF YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
THE RUNNING MATE SELECTION IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
VULNERABILITY, WHAT IS THE MAIN
VULNERABILITY CLINTON NEEDS TO
SOLVE?
JAMES: IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLLS,
ACROSS THE BOARD, SHE HAS TO
SHOW SHE IS IN IT FOR PEOPLE AS
OPPOSED TO HERSELF.
SHE HAS A LARGER MOTIVATION,
WHICH I THINK SHE DOES.
I THINK WARREN WOULD HELP THERE.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF
COLLEGE-EDUCATED REPUBLICANS, SO
SHE MIGHT WANT TO GO IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A FALSE
FLAG OPERATION, I WOULD NOT PUT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT PASTOR.
I HAPPEN TO THINK THE DEMOCRATIC
COALITION, IF YOU UNIFY IT, IT'S
HARD TO LOSE THE GENERAL
ELECTION FOR IF SHE CAN DO THAT,
I THINK SHE WILL BE FINE.
JOHN: WHAT PROBLEM DOES SHE NEED
TO SOLVE?
ANITA: SHE DOESN'T NEED TO SOLVE
ANYWHERE NEAR THE NUMBER OF
PROBLEMS DONALD TRUMP DOES IT
NEEDS TO SOLVE EXPERIENCE, THE
ABILITY TO GET THINGS DONE IN
WASHINGTON, FOREIGN POLICY THE
KNOWLEDGE AND BASIC TEMPERAMENT
AND QUALIFICATIONS, ALL OF WHICH
I THINK ARE UNSOLVABLE BY HIS
VICE PRESIDENT.
SHE COULD GO WITH A CANDIDATE
WHO IS A YOUNGER GENERATION THAT
COULD SEND THE MESSAGE ABOUT THE
TEACHER AND STRONGER TOGETHER,
DIVERSITY, OR AS JAMES SAID, SHE
COULD LOOK TO SOMEONE THAT COULD
COMMUNICATE THAT SHE REALLY DOES
CARE ABOUT PEOPLE.
THAT'S SOMEBODY IN THE ECONOMIC
SPIRIT LIKE SHERROD AROUND.
TIM KAINE IS A TERRIFIC GUY AND
GREAT CAMPAIGNER, FLUENT IN
SPANISH, WAS IN THE PEACE CORPS,
HAS THE EXPERIENCE AND
QUALIFICATIONS PEOPLE LOOK FOR,
AND HE WOULD BE ADDITIVE TO THE
TICKET, BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IT'S WHO DOES SHE THINK
SHOULD BE THE VICE PRESIDENT
BASED ON HER KNOWLEDGE AND
BELIEF ON WHO WOULD MAKE A GOOD
PRESIDENT.
SHE WILL MAKE A GOOD CHOICE.
MARK: ARE YOU GIVING ADVICE TO
HILLARY CLINTON THESE DAYS
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY?
JAMES: I'M GIVING INDIRECT
ADVICE ALL THE TIME.
BUT I THINK SHE SET ON GOING
THROUGH EACH THING.
I KNOW HER AND I KNOW SHE'S
GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS AND SHE
WILL LISTEN TO ANYTHING ANYBODY
HAS TO SAY FOR THE ONE THING I
DO THINK SHE NEEDS, HAVING RUN
AGAINST BOTH BERNIE SANDERS AND
DONALD TRUMP IS A LITTLE BIT
MORE OF THE STATUS QUO SIDE AND
SHE REALLY IS.
HOW CAN YOU BE MORE CHANGE THAN
DONALD TRUMP?
A VICE PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE THAT
WOULD SEND A SIGNAL THAT THERE
SOME CHANGE COMING WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT LAYS OUT
BUT I THINK IT IS SOMETHING SHE
SHOULD CONSIDER.
MARK: YOU TALK TO A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS IN THESE BATTLEGROUND
STATES.
WHAT IS YOUR OVERVIEW ABOUT HOW
DEMOCRATS ARE FEELING ABOUT
POSSIBLY LOSING TO TRUMP IN THIS
RACE?
ANITA: I THINK HOLES DONE IN
JULY AFTER YOU HAVE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT NEWS EVENT ARE NOT
CLOSE TO PREDICTIVE TO WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IN NOVEMBER.
TRUMP, BASED ON THE WORST MONTH
OF CAMPAIGNING --
MARK: ARE PEOPLE WORRIED IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
ANITA: I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ARE
WORRIED.
I THINK THEY UNDERSTAND IT'S
GOING TO BE A CLOSE RACE, THAT
WE HAVE TO WIN IT AND WE SHOULD
NOT TAKE IT FOR GRANTED.
I THINK DEMOCRATS LOOK AT TRUMP
AND THINK HOW COULD THAT GUY
WENT AND THERE IS A COMPLACENCY.
THESE POLLS SHOULD BE A WAKE-UP
CALL.
BUT I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ARE
WORRIED.
I THINK PEOPLE LOOK AT HER AND
SEE SOMEONE WHO CAN WIN THE
DEBATES, HAVE A GREAT
CONVENTION, AND IT'S A PLACE
WHERE SHE IS GOING TO WIN.
JOHN: IN THE WAKE OF LOUISIANA,
I KNOW YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THAT STATE, MINNESOTA AND
DALLAS, TRUMP IS PLAYING THE LAW
AND ORDER CARD.
IT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE NIXON IN
1968.
IS THAT SOMETHING HILLARY
CLINTON IS GOING TO HAVE TO
COUNTER DIRECTLY?
JAMES: I HEARD THAT THERE WERE
PEOPLE CALLING FOR A MOMENT OF
SILENCE FOR THE SHOOTER IN
DALLAS AND NOBODY CAN FIND SUCH
A THING.
I FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE IN ANY
SENSE THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING TO UNIFY AND ARE
CONCERNED THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
THE GO TO PERSON.
YOU KNOW I'M A DIEHARD DEMOCRAT
AND CLINTON SUPPORTER.
I DON'T SEE HOW HE'S PLAYING
THIS THING ANYTHING CLOSE TO THE
WAY THE COUNTRY IS LOOKING FOR.
WILL 38% OF THE COUNTRY AGREE
WITH HIM NO MATTER WHAT?
MAYBE SO.
BUT I DON'T ANYTHING THAT WILL
EXPAND HIS 38% AT ALL.
MARK: WHAT DO YOU WONDER ABOUT
THE REPUBLICAN CONVENTION ANITA:
I WONDER WHAT THE NARRATIVE IS
GOING TO BE.
IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT YOUR STORY THE WAY YOU
WANT TO PRESENT IT.
THEY HAVE NOT GIVEN US ANY
INDICATION OF WHAT THAT IS GOING
TO BE.
IT FEELS LIKE ONE OF THE
GREATEST OPPORTUNITIES HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO PRESENT HIS
STORY THE WAY HE WANTS TO
PRESENT IT.
CAN THEY RISE UP TO THAT
OCCASION?
CAN THEY USE IT THE WAY IT
SHOULD BE USED?
MARK: I NEED IT DONE AND JAMES
CARVILLE.
REALLY GOOD TO TALK TO YOU.
COMING UP, WE WILL TALK ABOUT A
POTENTIALLY MESSY RULES FIGHT
THAT COMES AHEAD OF THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION IN
CLEVELAND.
AND IF YOU ARE WATCHING US IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., YOU YOU CAN
LISTEN TO IS ON THE RADIO RADIO
AT 99.1 FM STOP MORE AFTER THIS.
♪
JOHN: THE REPUBLICAN CONVENTION
RULES COMMITTEE IS EXPECTED TO
HOLD ITS FIRST MEETING TOMORROW
WHEN THE NEVER TRUMP DELEGATES
WILL TRY TO FREE THEMSELVES FROM
THE SHACKLES OF VOTING FOR THEIR
PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE.
JOINING US IS OUR PUBLIC AND
ATTORNEY AND MSNBC ANALYSTS, BEN
GINSBERG.
WE'RE FINALLY ALMOST HERE AND IT
SEEMS LIKE THE TRUMP PEOPLE
THOUGHT THEY HAD IT UNDER
CONTROL UNTIL A COUPLE OF DAYS
AGO.
WE ARE STARTING TO HEAR THEY ARE
A LITTLE WORRIED.
THEN: ALL OF THIS IS A MOVING
TARGET.
THEY ARE NOTORIOUSLY UNRELIABLE
IN TERMS OF GIVING A HARD COUNT
AT THIS STAGE.
THE NOMINEES TEAM'S RIGHT TO
WORRY ALWAYS AND OPERATE AS IF
THE WORST COULD POSSIBLY HAPPEN.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS.
JOHN: IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
SITUATION ABOUT TO UNFOLD, WHAT
WILL YOU BE PAYING ATTENTION TO
TO MEASURE HOW IT IS GOING?
THEN: THE TEMPORARY COMMITTEE OF
THE RNC RULES WILL RUN HER THE
WHOLE LIST.
THERE'S A LOT OF TEST RULES I
WOULD SUSPECT FOLKS WILL BRING
OF TWO GAUGE STRENGTH THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY BE THE ATTEMPT TO
AMEND THE CURRENT RULES TO
INCLUDE THE CONSCIENCE CLAUSE OR
UNBINDING CLAUSE.
MARK: WHAT IS PROPELLING THINGS
IN A WORSE DIRECTION THAN THINGS
ARE HEADED, WHICH SOME OFFICIALS
SAY IS HAPPENING MARK >> I THINK
IT IS THE UNCERTAINTY OF THINGS.
PROBABLY PICKING A VICE
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE, IF IT IS
ONE THAT IS REASSURING TO THE
DELEGATES AND CAN MOVE IT TO THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND THE
INDECISION IS NOT HELPING
MATTERS.
THE FACT THERE'S NOT A
CONVENTION PROGRAM YET SUGGEST
IN A ROUNDABOUT WAY THAT THINGS
ARE NOT WHAT AND UP.
I THINK ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE UNCERTAINTY
THAT MEANS WHEN YOU TRY TO PIN
DOWN DELEGATES, THEY ARE PERHAPS
NOT ROCKSOLID AND WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING OR EVEN WORSE, JUST NOT
ANSWERING THEIR PHONE.
MARK: I KNOW IT'S HARD TO ANSWER
BECAUSE THE DELEGATES ARE NOT
MONOLITHIC.
BUT AMONG GINGRICH, PENS AND
CHRISTIE, IS THERE ONE OF THOSE
WHERE YOU WOULD THINK CONVENTION
IS GOING TO BE ALL EXCITED FOR
TRUMP AND RUNNING MATE ASK --
RUNNING MATE X?
THEN: I THINK EACH OF THEM
APPEALS TO DIFFERENT DELEGATES,
SO THE WHIP COUNT GETS TENTATIVE
AT THIS POINT.
I THINK EACH HAS STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES FOR PARTS OF THE
DELEGATE WILL.
THE WAY THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
PICKS IT DELEGATES IS SO
STATE-BY-STATE IDIOSYNCRATIC
THAT IT MAKES FIGURING OUT WHICH
BLOCKS THEIR ARE GOING TO GO
WITH REALLY CHALLENGING.
JOHN: EVEN IF THE TRUMP PEOPLE
WIN ON THE RULES MATTERS AND
WAY, IT'S POSSIBLY MINORITY WHIP
OR COULD BE ISSUED OUT OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE -- MINORITY
REPORT COULD BE ISSUED OUT OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
HOW MESSY COULD THAT GET, EVEN
IF THEY GET OVER THE HURDLE OF
NOT AMENDING THE RULES AND
COMMITTEE, HOW UGLY AND CHAOTIC
COULD IT BE IF THAT MINORITY
REPORT GETS OUT THERE?
THEN: ARGUING -- THEN -- BEN:
THERE ARE MINORITY REPORTS ALL
THE TIME AND HOUSE.
HE PUT A STRICT TIME LIMIT ON
IT, PROBABLY FIVE MINUTES ASIDE.
EVEN IF THE RHETORIC GETS HEATED
ON ONE SIDE OR ANOTHER, IT'S
PROBABLY FIVE MINUTES AND THEN A
VOTE.
WHAT IT'S MESSY IS THE LENGTH OF
TIME AND ROLLCALL PROCEDURES FOR
FIGURING OUT THAT VOTE AND IT IS
COMMON THE WATER FOR THE SHARKS.
IF A MINORITY REPORT GETS AN
UNUSUALLY LARGE NUMBER OF VOTES,
THEN THERE ARE THINGS TO DO
BEYOND THE CONSCIENCE CLAUSE
THAT WILL BE WORRISOME.
MARK: MUCH HAS BEEN MADE ABOUT
HOW SOME CORPORATE DONORS ARE
NOT ANTICIPATING AND FELLOW
REPUBLICAN ACTIVISTS AND
STRATEGISTS ARE NOT COMING
LARGELY BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP.
IN THE END, FOR A VIEWER,
REPUBLICAN OR INDEPENDENT, IS
THIS GOING TO COME ACROSS LIKE A
TYPICAL REPUBLICAN CONVENTION OR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND MAYBE
NOT AS GOOD IN TERMS OF
IMPACTING THE CHANCES OF THE
TICKET?
BEEN -- BEN: THE VISUALS DON'T
REFLECT ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST.
THE MEDIA COVERAGE IS WAY BEYOND
MY CONTROL TO JUDGE WHAT IS
WRITTEN AND SAID ABOUT IT.
THE ONE PART WHERE NOT BEING
THERE WILL MATTER IS IF ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL ROLLCALL VOTE THERE
ARE A LOT OF DELEGATE TO TRY TO
ABSTAIN IN DON'T COME IN FROM
THE SEATS.
THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
CONSCIENCE CLAUSE, BUT THAT IS A
LACE
ABSENCE OF ARTISTIC PATIENT.
--
JOHN: JUST FROM YOUR SLIGHT
OUTSIDER POSTURE, JUST JUDGING
THE WHOLE THING, DO YOU THINK
THE TRUMP FOLKS HAVE THEIR ACT
TOGETHER?
BEN: I THINK PARTS OF IT ARE
VERY MUCH TOGETHER FOR TOP FROM
WHAT I'VE SEEN IN THE PLOT FORM
COMMITTEE AND THE RNC MEETING
TODAY, IT IS A WHIP TEAM THAT IS
ACTING VERY WELL AND DOES HAVE
IT TOGETHER.
IT IS UNUSUAL AS YOU KNOW FROM
YOUR MANY YEARS OF COVERING
CONVENTIONS NOT TO HAVE THE
PROGRAM DONE, NOT TO HAVE
ANNOUNCED THE KEYNOTE.
THAT IS UNUSUAL AND DOES NOT
FEEL LIKE OTHER CONVENTIONS.
JOHN: THAT SEEMS LIKE A VERY
EVENHANDED ANALYSIS.
COMING UP, WE WILL BE BACK WITH
OUR REPORTERS NOTEBOOKS IN
CLEVELAND AFTER THIS.
♪
JOHN: HERE WITH US NOW IN
CLEVELAND FOR MORE ON THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION IS OUR
BLOOMBERG POLITICS REPORTER AND
A REPORTER FROM THE NEW YORK
TIMES.
YOU HAVE WRITTEN ABOUT ALL KINDS
OF TOPICS THAT HAVE COME
PERTINENT AS OF LATE.
TALK ABOUT OPEN CARRY AND THE
LAWS THAT PERTAIN TO THE STATE
AND WHAT IT MIGHT MEAN FOR WHAT
THE REPUBLICANS ARE FACING HERE.
GUEST: THE OPEN CARRY LAW MEANS
THAT THEY CAN BAN THINGS THAT
ARE TOO BIG LIKE -- THEY CANNOT
BAN BABY GUNS LIKE THE AR-15.
ANYONE COMING FROM AROUND THE
DATE, THEY CAN COME CARRY THEM
OPENLY AND THEY DON'T NEED A
PERMIT.
WHAT YOU COULD SEE IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE WITH A LOT OF GUNS AND
THEY COULD HAVE THEM LOADED OR
UNLOADED AND A LOT OF EVIL ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
I WROTE ABOUT PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT AFTER DALLAS THE DAY ARE
WORRIED IT'S GOING TO ADD TO AN
ALREADY CONFUSING NATIONAL
CONVENTION.
THE LAW IS YOU CAN HAVE GUNS
OUT.
JOHN: NOT JUST CONFUSION BUT
FEAR AND PARANOIA.
THEY SAY WE ARE GOING TO COME
PACKING.
GUEST: THERE ARE THOSE GROUPS
THERE.
THE SOUTHERN LAW POVERTY CENTER
DESCRIBES THEM AS A REALLY
MILITANT EXTREMIST GROUP BUT
THEY SAY THEY ARE THERE TO HELP
THE POLICE OFFICERS DO THEIR JOB
AND SHOOT SOMEBODY IS THINGS GET
OUT OF HAND.
THERE IS A PRO TRUMP GROUP
HAVING A BIG CELEBRATION RALLY
AND THEY SAY THEY ARE GOING TO
BAN PEOPLE FROM CARRYING LONG
ARMS AND THERE LIKE THE AR-15.
THEY DO HAVE A PERMIT AND THEY
CAN KICK PEOPLE OUT BUT IF
SOMEONE HAS A LOADED AR-15 AND
YOU ARE TELLING THEM NOT TO COME
TO THE PARK, IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD.
MARK: TALK ABOUT YOUR GENERAL
SENSE OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
MANAGER RELATIONSHIP TO THE RNC
AND THE DELEGATES AT THIS EVENT.
MIKE: I'VE BEEN TALKING TO SOME
DELEGATES AND RNC MEMBERS
WORKING ON THE PLAT FORM
COMMITTEE, GETTING READY FOR THE
RULES COMING OUT AND I'M EXCITED
TO BE HERE IN CLEVELAND.
IT IS MY HOMETOWN AND IT'S AN
EXCITING TIME BUT I'M NOT EATING
THE SAME EXCITEMENT FROM
DELEGATES AND RNC MEMBERS,
ESPECIALLY THE FOLKS PUTTING THE
PLAT THEM TOGETHER YESTERDAY.
THEY HAVE NO REASON TO BELIEVE
TRUMP IS GOING TO BE CAMPAIGNING
ON ANY OF THESE ISSUES THAT THEY
HAVE SPENT WEEKS AND MONTHS ON.
VIRGINIA FOXX WAS RIGHT TO TEARS
AFTER PUTTING THIS PLATFORM
COMMITTEE TOGETHER AND THERE'S A
DISCONNECT HERE BETWEEN THE
DELEGATES AND THE CANDIDATE.
I TALKED TO SOME FOLKS IS THAT
WE ARE BUILDING OUR PLATFORM,
HE'S RUNNING OUR CAMPAIGN, AND
IT JUST THE WAY THINGS WILL BE
FULL OF NOT A LOT OF REAL
EXCITEMENT THERE.
ASKING WHAT THEY LIKED ABOUT
TRUMP.
A LOT OF FOLKS SAY HE'S NOT
CLINTON.
I THINK THAT CAN BE AN EFFECTIVE
CLINICAL MESSAGE BUT I'M NOT
SURE HOW MUCH EXCITEMENT THAT
REFLECTS.
MARK: TALK ABOUT THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND HERE.
YOU GOT THE SACRED -- THE SECRET
SERVICE.
IF THERE ARE PROTESTS TO BE
DEALT WITH, WHO TAKES THE LEAD
ON THAT AND HOW TO THINGS LAYOUT
OF EVIL ACTUALLY GET ARRESTED?
GUEST: MY SENSE OF WHO TAKES THE
LEAD AS THE CLEVELAND POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
A JUDGE HOLDING COURT 20 HOURS A
DAY, HE EXPECTS ALL ARRESTING
DOCUMENTS TO BE FILLED OUT BY
CLEVELAND POLICE OFFICERS AND
STRESSED OFFICERS COMING AS FAR
AWAY FROM CALIFORNIA, THAT THEY
WILL BE COMING HERE AND THEY
UNDERSTAND THE CLEVELAND POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS THE LEAD A ARE
FOLLOWING.
I SHOULD SAY IN THIS CASE, THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT IS UNDER A
CONSENT DECREE, SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
WATCHING BECAUSE THEY WERE FOUND
TO BE BIASED.
IN SOME WAYS, THE LOCALS ARE IN
CHARGE BUT THE DOJ IS WATCHING
CLOSELY FOR TOP -- WATCHING
CLOSELY.
JOHN: WHAT ARE THE DELEGATES
THINKING IN THE DUMP TRUMP
MOVEMENT THINKING?
MIKE: WHAT THEY ARE TELLING ME
IS THAT IT IS MOSTLY AP OR A
VICTORY -- MOSTLY A FURYK
VICTORY --
THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
PROCESS.
THE PRIMARIES SHOULD BE A DATA
POINT ON HOW THEY SHOULD VOTE ON
THE FLOOR OF THE CONVENTION
WHICH IS AN INHERENT FLAW IN
THIS ARGUMENT.
IF YOU ARE NOT FOR TRUMP, YOU
HAVE TO BE FOR SOMEONE, BUT THEY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE PROCESS
AND HOW TO PULL THE PARTY
TOGETHER.
IF IT LEADS TO SOMEONE OTHER
THAN TRUMP, GREAT, BUT IT'S HARD
TO MOTIVATE A LOT OF NOOKS.
JOHN: WHO IS TRUMP GOING TO
PICK?
MIKE: GINGRICH.
GUEST: GINGRICH.
JOHN: THANK YOU.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: MORE OF OUR COVERAGE OF
THE VEEP STAKES ON BLOOMBERG.COM
AND WE HAVE A REVISED BLOOMBERG
POLITICS NEWSLETTER FOR YOU TO
SUBSCRIBE TO.
COMING UP, EMILY CHANG TALKS TO
THE GOOGLE SENIOR POLICY
COUNCIL.
MORE FROM CLEVELAND AND MORE ON
HILLARY CLINTON MEETING WITH TIM
KAINE.
WE WILL HAVE ALL OF THAT FOR YOU
TOMORROW.
THANKS FOR WATCHING.
SAYONARA.
♪
MARK: I'M MARK CRUMPTON.
LET'S BEGIN WITH A CHECK OF YOUR
FIRST WORD NEWS.
LEADERSHIP OFFICIALLY CHANGED
HANDS TODAY IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
THERESA MAY BECAME